a water's world investigation nancy
pelosi's policies are making it harder
and harder for average americans to
accumulate wealth
shackling us with taxes destroying the
dollar with reckless spending but the
speaker who makes in the low six figures
has somehow very easily become one of
the richest members of congress
what's her secret it appears to be her
husband paul
after they got married paul opened up a
real estate and venture capital firm and
through his connections he pushed nancy
into the political world helping her get
elected to congress in 1987. the couple
has timed the market perfectly over the
years while nancy's been a washington
insider real estate stocks the pelosi's
always know what the right investment is
since getting married they've acquired a
mansion in napa valley a vineyard home
worth up to 25 million real luxury it's
on 16 acres
pelosi has a gorgeous waterfront condo
in the exclusive k street region in dc
now worth over 2 mil
she has a multi-million dollar red brick
mansion in california's pacific heights
and paul owns at least two commercial
properties in san francisco combined
worth
up to 50 million dollars
since regaining the gavel in 2018 the
pelosi's wealth has skyrocketed that
year her financial disclosure report
revealed a net worth of over 114 million
then in 2019 pelosi's assets totaled up
to a whopping
271 million and in 2020 those numbers
went up even more to as high as
315 million bucks quite a lot of crumbs
so where's the money coming from
60 minutes basically accused paul pelosi
of insider trading
madam leader
i wanted to ask you why you and your
husband back in march of 2008
accepted and participated in a very
large ipo deal from visa at a time there
was major
legislation affecting their credit card
companies making its way through the um
through the house
and did you consider that to be a
conflict of interest
i don't know what your point is of your
question is there some point that you
want to make with that well i i guess
what i'm asking is do you think it's all
right for uh a speaker uh to accept uh a
very preferential and favorable uh stock
deal what would you do you participated
in the ipo
and at the time you were speaker of the
house you don't think it was a conflict
of interest or have the appearance of a
conflict
only has appearance if you decide that
you're going to have a a elaborate on a
false premise but it it it's not true
and that's that i don't understand what
part's not true
yes sir
that i would act upon an investment
in 2007 visa worried the new democrat
congress would target their swipe fees
costing them billions so they hired a
team of lobbyists who descended on
pelosi visa's ceo personally met with
her she got donations from him one of
nancy's advisors left and became a visa
lobbyist himself the old inside outside
game
now get this suddenly paul pelosi got a
phone call from his broker he was in
luck paul was offered a pre-screened
invite to get in early on visa's 18
billion dollar ipo
did nancy and her husband hesitate
no they bought between 1 million and 5
million worth of visa stock but it gets
better
while pelosi was speaker bills that
would have hurt visas stock price were
blocked in the house
visa shares going up over 200 percent
during the time making the pelosi's a
fortune on paper
nancy pelosi and her husband have a
knack for taking advantage of market
timing in march
paul pelosi exercised two million
dollars worth of microsoft options just
two weeks before the tech giant got a 22
billion dollar contract to equip the us
army with high-tech headsets
in january the pelosi's got a million
dollars worth of tesla stock right
before joe biden announced electric car
incentives
in june the pelosi family cashed in big
time just before congress was set to
pounce on big tech
mr pelosi exercised options on google's
parent company alphabet making an easy
5.3 mill
now to be fair the pelosi's have never
been indicted for insider trading but
her marriage investments and access
combined with extremely fortunate timing
have created a lot of suspicions
all we're doing is following the money
and there sure is a lot of it
joining me now for more on this
president of the government
accountability institute and the drill
down podcast host peter schweitzer
all right we put it together for you
there peter what is your reaction you
know better than anybody how this whole
thing works
yeah i know i i think you're dead on
look the bottom line jesse is we don't
mind if people make money with
investments the question is is it wedded
to your political power and in the case
of the pelosi's they not only got that
visa ipo stock they've participated in
at least 10
ipo
stocks and these are unusual these
basically go to company founders and
insiders the fact that a politician's
family is allowed to participate in an
investment that when it goes public
generally doubles in value often is is a
real indicator that there's a problem
i'll add one other thing jesse those
office buildings you mentioned they own
an office building on belden street in
san francisco
nancy pelosi steered 200 million dollars
in federal money to build the third
avenue light railway system in san
francisco
guess where one of the stops of that
light railway system actually stops
within two blocks of their office
building that matters because there's
something called the transit premium if
your building is within two blocks of a
subway or railway stop it effectively
doubles the value of it and that's
precisely what happened to the pelosi's
real estate that's very interesting also
interesting they've been offered 10
ipo
buy-ins so it's just randomly that these
companies give the pelosi family early
access to ipos unbelievably
fortunate
people nancy and paul all right peter
thank you for following the money with
us
you're good
thanks for having me hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else